Kate is so good to see you thanks so
much for joining us and I do love this
holiday decor and we're gearing up for
the holidays do you have any special
holiday traditions well usually it
involves a cat and a dog
um one of the things is really important
to Tidy Cats and me is being able to
gift
um give back to Shelby or local shelter
around the holidays so donate you know
uh kitty litter food time you don't have
to write a check it's just like a nice
way to give back how long have you had
Pablo I adopted him when I got him when
he was six weeks old he's now 18. he
still enjoys a little catnip Mouse but
that's another thing we do on the
holidays keep all the toys in a basket
like a nice decorative basket on the
side so nobody slips on a yeah on a
mouse
that's why we teamed up with Kate and
Tidy Cats for more perfect tips to make
your home festive and Feline friendly
and then you know for the holidays like
I've got my artificial tree up you know
if you've got a cat or a dog you want to
be really careful if you do have a fresh
tree because they're going to want to go
into that water and have a drink we're
gonna have a little party so yeah we
move the kitty litter from the guest
bathroom into another room you got to
make sure that it's a quiet area and I
love the Tidy Cats lightweight litter
it's 99.9 dust free and it's also got a
very light subtle linen scent which I
love the cat loves because you don't
want it too perfumey I love that um you
have the best cat ever
foreign